what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so with all the hype surrounding
the Logan movie which looks like it's
going to be absolutely amazing I wanted
to bring you guys the different types of
adamantium in Marvel Comics what I also
think we need to do here is take a
second and acknowledge the fact that
after 17 years Hugh Jackman
will no longer be playing wool brain
unless of course the Marvel Cinematic
Universe gets the x-men which I don't
think they will
Fox is that Fox doesn't like Marvel I
guess but I think it was kind of
necessary sort of just say thank you to
the Hugh Jackman for playing such an
awesome character but having said that
there are multiple types of adamantium
within the realm of Marvel Comics now
when I say multiple types usually it
just appears in different universes but
even within the main Marvel Universe
there are a few different types of this
of this metal so I kind of wanted to run
through these and see what we can see we
are going to start with the original
form of adamantium which is referred to
as proto adamantium now for those of you
guys who saw my video on the origin of
this bear with me for seconds because
we're going to kind of rehash this for a
second just because the fact that you
know the very least I want to go ahead
and make it make sense so the creation
of proto man TM goes back to World War
two when the metallurgist dr. Maya
MacLean was commissioned by the United
States government to create a new armor
for soldiers that would basically be
indestructible now MacLean goes to work
experimenting with another metal known
as vibranium which he attempts to fuse
with a developmental steel alloy now
during the fusion process MacLean
accidentally falls asleep and wakes up
only to find out that he's created a
virtually indestructible metal and so
this particular material will be poured
into a mold that would later become
Captain America's shield now after the
success of this experiment MacLean tried
once again to repeat his results and
make more of the vibranium alloy what he
didn't know was that while he was asleep
and unknown catalyst had somehow been
introduced into his original experiment
now because the catalyst was not present
in the subsequent experiments MacLean
was never able to duplicate the results
of the
experiment but what he did create was a
metal that was nearly as strong and
indestructible as his original creation
now this metal is what most of us know
as true adamantium or simply put the
metal despondent to Wolverine's skeleton
now as we stated earlier of the two
proto adamantium is the stronger and
more durable metal to get an idea of how
strong we can look at what it takes to
break Captain America's shield now to
the best of my research I was only able
to find five times that Captain
America's shields been broken in the
entire history of Marvel Comics it was
broken once by molecule man Owen Reese's
reality-warping powers once by dr. doom
when he possessed the powers of the
Beyonder once by Thanos really the
Infinity Gauntlet once by Thor using the
Thor force and once by Odin's brothers a
serpent who had made himself stronger by
drawing on the fear of the entire
population of Earth now true adamantium
sometimes referred to as primary
adamantium though not quite as strong as
proto adamantium is still virtually
indestructible although it has been
shown to be susceptible to manipulation
by magneto as evidenced by the time that
he ripped the adamantium from Wolverine
skeleton still we're talking about a
metal here that can withstand blows from
the strongest characters in the Marvel
Universe including the Hulk juggernaut
in the century and still will go without
being damaged in addition to being
almost indestructible true adamantium is
able to cut through pretty much any
substance on earth with the lone to
exception being Captain America shield
and Thor's hammer now another key
difference between these types of
adamantium is that while proto
adamantium cracks hitherto not been able
to be reproduced true adamantium has
although the process for doing so is
quite difficult and expensive in order
to produce adamantium its components
have to be kept in separate containers
before being melted together once we
always mixed it must be cast within
eight minutes due to the highly stable
molecular structure that does not allow
adamantium to remoulded after that point
regardless of how hot it gets now
because producing adamantium is so
difficult and Costco hibbett 'iv another
form of adamantium was developed known
as secondary adamantium we're introduced
to this concept in Avenger vol 3 issue
number 22 when the Avengers are battling
an army of Ultron now while the original
iteration of Ultron is constructed out
of true adamantium and wasn't that the
first character to appear Marvel comic
that wielded that metal the copies of
Ultron that make up his army are not
during the battle Ironman remarked that
there's not enough true adamantium on
earth to build such a high number of
Ultron's and explained that most of the
copies are made out of titanium steel
but that some were made out of a
substance called secondary adamantium
now we don't know exactly how this
differs from true adamantium in terms of
composition what we do know is that
while it is still incredibly strong it's
not as strong as true adamantium and the
reason we noticed is that Iron Man
states that Thor would be able to smash
through secondary adamantium if you were
to go all-out another thing that we
learned in this issue concerns our
previous point that adamantium cannot be
reshaped after its forged according to
Tony Stark this is true of secondary
adamantium as well as he states that the
only way to reshape the metal is to
rearrange its molecules the way he
achieves this is through an instrument
called the molecular rearranger which is
not the most creative name but there is
one of these rearranged errs inside each
adamantium Ultron that's keyed to a
batch of adamantium at the time it's
manufactured and can only work on the
Ultron that was made from that batch
however Tony is able to supercharge one
of the rear Rangers and knock out
several of the adamantium Ultron's at
once now to circle back around to the
case of Wolverine one of the questions
that's often imposed regarding is
adamantium lay skeleton it's how the
metal interacted with Wolverines biology
now we know that Wolverines written
healing factor is what prevents him from
being poisoned by the adamantium in his
body but there is more at play here in
Wolverine vol 2 issue number 80 it was
established that when true adamantium
was bonded to Wolverine's skeleton a
molecular change occurred that resulted
in the creation of an entirely new type
of adamantium known as adamantium beta
and what makes adamantium beta special
is that it's able to regenerate as
Wolverines bones regenerate so although
this is a distinct type of adamantium it
seems to only exist when bonded with the
biology of individuals with healing
factors like Wolverine and Sabretooth
now in terms of the main Marvel line of
adamantium this is pretty much it but
there are a few other types of
adamantium that exist in the whole of
Marvel Comics an x-men issue number 191
a character named Serafina states that
there are actually 13 different physical
forms in which adamantium can exist all
of which are unstable and extremely
poisonous
what she does in this story is she
throws a device
one of those allotropes which he refers
to as adamantium 9 at Wolverine which
causes his claws to glow green and also
causes him to become confused and faint
there's also another variation of
adamantium that's contained in the
tentacles of the villain Omega red which
is known as carbonadium now carbonadium
is the result of a russian experiment to
create adamantium and while it's not as
durable as adamantium it's vastly more
flexible and almost as indestructible
furthermore carbonadium is highly
radioactive and has been shown to
suppress healing factors of individuals
like Wolverine himself now in the
Ultimate Comics adamantium is not nearly
as durable as its main Universe
counterpart and has been broken by
characters such as Hulk and Valkyrie
however this version of adamantium is
able to prevent telepaths from reading
minds which the main universe version
cannot do on the other hand not much
else is known about adamantium in the
Ultimate Universe so we don't know who
created it or how and because the
Ultimate Universe was effectively wiped
away from Marvel Comics during the
events of secret Wars we probably never
will now finally a particular importance
to this video is the version of
adamantium that we've seen in the x-men
movie universe while this version seems
to have the same properties of a comics
version its history is vastly different
we don't know exactly how the metal was
created only that it was created by
William Stryker who collected a great
deal of an unnamed element from the site
of a meteorite crash in Africa also
unlike the college version the movie
version about a man team can be cut
through by another piece of adamantium
that's been heated at an extremely high
temperature as evidenced by the scene in
the Wolverine or silver samurai cuts
through Wolverines claws but when a
being said guys this pretty much covers
adamantium that is to say the concept of
adamantium in Marvel Comics but there
are other metals and other different
materials in Marvel that are sort of
knock-offs or that in some way different
from adamantium we are relatively close
to strength and durability a really good
example is uber metal which is actually
what Thor's hammer is composed of but if
you guys want to see more videos like
this to make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah let me know down in
the comments section how height you guys
are about Wolverine because I'm really
really excited and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]